>>> THE WHITE HOUSE
ANNOUNCED AN ADDITIONAL $600
MILLION IN SECURITY AID TO
UKRAINE.
THESE HAVE BECOME REGULAR
EVENTS, IT BRINGS THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF U.S. MILITARY
ASSISTANCE TO MORE THAN $15
BILLION SINCE RUSSIA BEGAN ITS
INVASION MORE THAN SIX MONTHS
AGO.
THAT ANNOUNCEMENT CAME AS THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED A
MASS GRAVE WAS DISCOVERED IN THE
EASTERN CITY OF IZIUM.
ONE OF THE AREAS RECENTLY
LIBERATED FROM RUSSIAN INVADERS.
UKRAINIAN AUTHORITIES SAY THEY
FOUND 440 GRAVES THERE, SOME OF
THEM FRESH.
THE BODIES BURIED MOSTLY
CIVILIANS.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS THE
STATE OF THE WAR, RETIRED U.S.
ARMY GENERAL DAVID PETRAEUS,
FORMER COMMANDER OF U.S. CENTRAL
COMMAND.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON TODAY.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> SO THAT MASS GRAVE IS THE
RESULT OF WHAT IS POSITIVE
PROGRESS FOR UKRAINIAN FORCES
TAKING BACK TERRITORY AFTER A
VERY SWIFT RETREAT REALLY FROM
RUSSIANS IN THE NORTHEAST, THE
SECOND BIG RETREAT WE'VE SEEN
SINCE THE START OF THIS
INVASION, INCLUDING THAT AROUND
THE CAPITAL KYIV.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN ABOUT THE
STATE OF THE WAR RIGHT NOW?
HAS THE MOMENTUM FUNDAMENTALLY
SHIFTED?
>> IT HAS FUNDAMENTALLY SHIFTED.
I'M FAIRLY GUARDED AND CAUTIOUS
ABOUT THIS, BUT THE TIDE CLEARLY
HAS TURNED BECAUSE THE SUCCESS
OF THIS OFFENSIVE, AS IMPORTANT
AS IT IS ITSELF ON THE GROUND,
WHAT REALLY IS IMPORTANT IS THAT
IT REFLECTS A HUGELY IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENT, A NEW REALITY, THAT
UKRAINE HAS BEEN INCOMPARABLE
BLEE BETTER THAN RUSSIA IN
RECREATING, TRAINING, EQUIPPING,
ORGANIZING AND EMPLOYING
ADDITIONAL FORCES.
WHILE RUSSIA HAS BEEN STRUGGLING
TO DO JUST THAT, LITERALLY
RUNNING OUT OF SOLDIERS,
AMMUNITION, TANKS, FIGHTING
VEHICLES AND SO FORTH.
THE UKRAINES SUPPORTED SUPERBLY
BY THE U.S. AND NATO, WHEREAS
RUSSIA EACH IF IT DECLARED
MOBILIZATION TODAY COULD NOT
REVERSE THIS FUNDAMENTAL REEEL.
SO THE IMPLICATIONS ARE STARK.
THEY'RE VERY CLEAR.
UKRAINE WILL OVER TIME AND, YES,
TOUGH FIGHTING, MORE CASUALTIES,
MORE PUNISHING RUSSIAN STRIKES
ON CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
UKRAINE WILL OVER TIME, I THINK,
RETAKE THE TERRITORY THAT RUSSIA
HAS SEIZED SINCE 24 FEBRUARY AND
IT'S EVEN CONCEIVABLE NOW THAT
THEY COULD RETAKE CRIMEA AND THE
DONBAS AND, OH, BY THE WAY, WITH
WHAT'S GOING ON ON THE FRONT
LINES THERE IS UNSURGEGE ENT
ACTIVITY PICKING UP IN THE
RUSSIAN REAR AREAS CARRIED OUT
BY UKRAINIANS THERE AS WELL.
THIS IS GOING TO TAKE TIME,
THERE WILL BE TOUGH FIGHTING,
ALL OF THAT, BUT THIS IS A
DISASTROUS SITUATION FOR RUSSIA
NOW.
I'M NOT SURE THAT EVERYONE
RECOGNIZES JUST HOW -- WORSE
THAN AFGHANISTAN.
REMEMBER THEY LEFT AFGHANISTAN,
THE GOVERNMENT THEY LEFT BEHIND
STAYED IN POWER FOR TWO YEARS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A TERRIBLE,
PAINFUL RETREAT FOR THEM.
AND, AGAIN, YOU KNOW, THE
OUTCOME JUST IS I DON'T THINK IN
DOUBT ANYMORE.
UKRAINE WILL PREVAIL UNLESS
THERE'S SOME UNFORESEEN
DEVELOPMENT AND AS LONG AS WE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE WEAPONS
AND OF COURSE YOU NOTED THE
LATEST ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT THAT,
I'M CONFIDENT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO EVERYTHING THAT THEY NEED
TO HELP THEM BUILD ON THE
MOMENTUM THAT THEY HAVE NOW
ACHIEVED AND CARRY THIS ALL THE
WAY THROUGH TO VICTORY, FRANKLY.
>> SO LET ME ASK YOU YOUR READ
OF PUTIN'S NEXT MOVE HERE
BECAUSE, FOR INSTANCE, BEYOND
THE LOSING THE GROUND THAT
RUSSIAN FORCES HAD GAINED SINCE
THE INVASION, YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT LOSING GROUND WHICH RUSSIA
HAS HELD FOR EIGHT YEARS IN
CRIMEA AND WHICH, BY THE WAY,
THE KREMLIN VIEWS AS
STRATEGICALLY ESSENTIAL, RIGHT?
I MEAN, THAT IS THEIR WARM WATER
PORT IN CRIMEA AND SO ON.
DO YOU THEN FEAR THAT PUTIN
TAKES A STEP BEYOND WHERE HE'S
GONE NOW, WHETHER IT'S FULL
MOBILIZATION OR EVEN USE OF
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION?
>> WELL, AGAIN, FULL
MOBILIZATION IS TOO LATE AND
BEYOND THAT THEY'VE STRIPPED
THEIR BASE, THEY DON'T HAVE THE
REPLACEMENT VEHICLES, THE EXPORT
SANCTIONS ON MICRO CHIPS TO
RUSSIA HAVE CRUSHED THEIR
INDUSTRIAL BASE AND SO FORTH.
THAT'S TOO LATE.
THE CONSIDERATION OF TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, YES, YOU COULD
HAVE A TACTICALLY VERY
DISASTROUS SITUATION BUT IT
DOESN'T CHANGE THE FUNDAMENTAL
REALITIES WHICH ARE THAT RUSSIA
JUST CANNOT GENERATE THE FORCES,
MUCH LESS EMPLOY THEM CAPE PLEA
AND COMPETENTLY.
THEIR MORALE IS ROCK BOTTOM,
THEY ARE NOT EVEN SURE WHAT
THEY'RE FIGHTING FOR OTHER THAN
A PAYCHECK OR PERHAPS TO STAY
OUT OF JAIL.
THE MORALE ON THE UKRAINIAN SKY
IS SKY HIGH, THEY'RE WINNING.
SO THE QUESTION AT FIRST IS CAN
THE RUSSIANS FIND NEW DEFENSIVE
LINES OR DO THEY HAVE TO FALL
ALL THE WAY BACK IN THE EAST,
FOR EXAMPLE, TO THE ORIGINAL
LINES OF THE DONBAS, WHERE THERE
ARE VERY CONSIDERABLE ALMOST
WORLD WAR I-LIKE DEFENSES AND
THEN HOW DO THEY HANG ON IN
THESE OTHER LOCATIONS.
YES, THEY WILL FIND PLACES WHERE
THEIR URBAN SETTINGS THAT THEY
CAN USE EFFECTIVELY AND FIGHT
HARD, AGAIN, THERE WILL BE TOUGH
FIGHTING, TOUGH CASUALTIES, A
LOT MORE DAMAGE, BUT RUSSIA IS
IN, AGAIN, A TRULY DISASTROUS
SITUATION AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
AND CROSSING THE NUCLEAR
THRESHOLD WOULD BE SO PROFOUND
AND THE BENEFIT OF THAT WOULD
NOT BE AS PROFOUND.
SO I THINK, AGAIN, HE'S IN A
VERY DIFFICULT POSITION.
HE'S GOING TO TRY TO CHANGE THE
NARRATIVE, BLAME OTHERS AND ALL
THE REST OF THIS AND FIND SOME
WAY TO EXPLAIN WHY THE SPECIAL
OPERATION HAS FAILED.
>> SO LET ME ASK YOU, YOU
MENTIONED THE COMPARISON TO THE
AFGHANISTAN WAR, RUSSIA'S
EXPERIENCE IN AFGHANISTAN IN THE
'80s.
IT TOOK RUSSIA NEARLY A DECADE
TO LOSE AS MANY TROOPS AS ITS
LOST IN THE SPAN OF MONTHS,
FRANKLY MORE IN UKRAINE NOW.
AFGHANISTAN HELPED LEAD TO THE
FALL OF SOVIET UNION.
I WONDER IN YOUR VIEW IS
PRESIDENT PUTIN'S LEADERSHIP NOW
IN JEOPARDY GIVEN ALL HE'S
INVESTED IN THIS INVASION?
>> WELL, HE STILL CLEARLY HAS A
VERY, VERY SOLID GRIP ON POWER
IN RUSSIA, BUT THIS DOES
OBVIOUSLY CALL THAT INTO
QUESTION SOMEWHAT AND SOMEWHERE
THERE ARE GOING TO BE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
RAISING SERIOUS QUESTIONS.
THERE HAVE BEEN OFFICIALS, OF
COURSE, FROM ST. PETERSBURG THAT
SUGGESTED HE SHOULD RESIGN, THEY
ENDED UP IN JAIL, BUT THEN THERE
WERE OTHERS FROM ST. PETERSBURG
AND MOSCOW.
SO, AGAIN, HE IS IN A PRECARIOUS
SITUATION, I THINK, ALTHOUGH
IT'S SO DIFFICULT TO PREDICT
WHEN SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN AN
AUTOCRAT OBVIOUSLY WHAT IS THAT
MOMENT THAT PUSHES THEM OFF THE
THRONE?
OF COURSE, HE IS A KLEPTO
DEM CRAT
AND EVERYONE IS EMPOWERED BY
HIM.
WHAT HE HAS DONE TO HIS COUNTRY,
HE SET OUT TO MAKE RUSSIA GREAT
AGAIN, HE HAS REALLY MADE NATO
GREAT AGAIN.
BY THE WAY, THIS CHANGES THE
DYNAMIC, I THINK, WITH RESPECT
TO EUROPEAN AND U.S. RELUCTANCE
TO SAY THAT UKRAINE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO JOIN NATO.
GIVEN WHAT RUSSIA HAS DONE,
THERE HAS TO BE A SECURITY -- AT
THE END OF THIS.
THE ONLY CREDIBLE GUARANTEE IS
NATO MEMBERSHIP AND WE CAN THEN
SAY, LOOK, YOU BROUGHT THIS ON
YOURSELF.
WE WERE VERY SENSITIVE TO YOUR
FEELINGS BEFORE, WE DID NOT WANT
TO NEEDLESSLY PROVOKE YOU.
YOU HAVE NEEDLESSLY AND
UNPROVOKED INVASION OF YOUR
NEIGHBOR AND THIS IS THE PRICE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO PAY AS A
RESULT OF THAT.
>> GOODNESS.
WELL, WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN NATO
EXPAND WITH FINLAND AND SWEDEN.
IS THAT THE NEXT STEP?
GENERAL DAVID PETRAEUS,
FASCINATING ASSESSMENT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS QUESTIONS
AND CONCERNS ABOUT RUSSIA'S.
>> WE HIGHLY APPRECIATE THE
BALANCE POSITION OF OUR CHINESE
FRIENDS IN CONNECTION WITH THE
UKRAINIAN CRISIS.
WE&YOUR QUESTIONS AND CONCERN IN
THIS REGARD.
DURING TODAY'S MEETING WE WILL
EXPLAIN IN DETALL, OUR.
>> AND JOINING ME NOW IS THE
FORM ARES AUTHOR OF LESSONS FROM
THE EDGE," A MEMOIR.
SHE TESTIFIED AFTER BEING
TARGETED BY TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES
AFTER IMPOZING A HOW ARE YOU
SEEING THIS?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S EVIDENCE
OF RUSSIA'S INCREASING ISOLATION
IN THE WORLD COMMUNITY WHERE
BACK IN FEBRUARY YOU'LL RECALL
THE TWO LEADERS MET AND THEY
TALKED ABOUT A PARTNERSHIP
WITHOUT LIMITS.
AND NOW, YOU KNOW, OVER THE
MONTHS WE'VE SEEN THAT CHINA HAS
NOT PROVIDED THE KIND OF SUPPORT
THAT I THINK RUSSIA WAS HOPING
FOR WHEN THEY FUND THE MILITARY
TIED AND NOW THEY HAVE A SUMMIT
WHERE PRZ PS.
>> YES, SUPPORT WITHOUT LIMITS
NOW APPEARS TO HAVE IS PRRNG.
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING KNOW
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
>> AMBASSADOR, I UNDERSTAND YOU
WERE.
GIVEN THE EVENTS WE'VE ALL
UNSEEN SO RAPIDLY.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON HOW THIS
HAPPENED AND WHAT IT PORTENDS?
>> YEAH, SO IF I COULD JUST SAY
A WORD ABOUT BEING IN KYIV, IT
WAS REALLY INSPIRING.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE COURAGEOUS,
THEY ARE COMMITTED AND THEY ARE
CONFIDENT.
THEY ARE CONFIDENT THAT THEY
WILL PREVAIL IN THIS FIGHT WITH
RUSSIA.
AND ALL OF THAT WAS BEFORE THE
GOOD WILL AND SUPPORT WAS COMING
IN.
AND FOR ME IT WAS DOWNRIGHT --
IT WAS REALLY WONDERFUL.
>> I MEAN, GOING -- HOW DID U.
>> I THINK IT'S THE RESULT OF
FRORS FRMS I THINK,EN, THE
COURAGE OF THE UKRAINIAN TROOPS,
I THINK IT'S GOOD PLANNING.
AND THE ABILITY TO USE DECEPTION
WITH THE RUSSIAN MILITARY SO
THAT THE SO THIS EWILL LOVE.
OVER THE LAST WEEK OR SO WILL
PROBABLY SLOW DOWN.
THEY'VE LOST SOME OF THAT
ELEMENT OF SURPRISE.
I THINK THEY'RE CONTINUING TO
PRESS FORWARD AND I THINK WE'LL
CONTINUE TO SEE SUCCESS ON THE
PART OF UKRAINIANS.